IT’S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
JAMES COMEY BROKE FBI RULES BUT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, THEY
WILL NOT PROSECUTE HIM.
A SCATHING NEW DOJ
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT DETAILS
HOW THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
HANDLED MEMOS ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY REPORT LAYING OUT NUMEROUS
VIOLATIONS BY JAMES COMEY, AMONG
THEM VIOLATING POLICY BY GIVING
A MEMO TO A FRIEND WITH
INSTRUCTIONS TO SHARE IT WITH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
HE ALSO KEPT COPIES OF THE MEMOS
IN A SAFE AT HIS HOME.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL SAME THE
FORMER HEAD OF THE FBI SENT A
"DANGEROUS EXAMPLE" FOR THE
BUREAU BUT COMEY IS INSISTING
HE’S BEEN CLEARED AND EVEN
TOTTING HIS CRITICS."
"ALTHOUGH SPENT TWO YEARS
TALKING TO BE GOING TO JAIL OR
BEING A LIAR AND A LEAKER,
ASK YOURSELF WHY YOU STILL
TRUST PEOPLE WHO GAVE YOU THAT
INFO FOR SO LONG INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT.
"PRESIDENT TRUMP IS RESPONDING
BY SAYING COMEY SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF HIMSELF.
AS SOMEONE WHO’S BEEN IN
CONGRESS, I’M GOING TO ASK, DO
YOU AGREE WITH WHAT THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND AND THE
DECISION NOT TO PROSECUTE?
WELL, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
PERKO RECOMMENDED HE BE PROSECUE
PERKO RECOMMENDED HE BE PROSECU.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
OPERATING A DIFFERENT LEVEL HAS
DECIDED NOT TO DO THIS.
I FIND IT VERY TROUBLING THERE
ARE MULTIPLE TIMES THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS MADE HER
RECOMMENDATIONS TO PROSECUTE
INCLUDING THE DEPUTY ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR AND OTHERS.
THEY HAVEN’T PROSECUTED.
I THINK THAT’S A PROBLEM AND I
THINK IT’S AT THAT TERRIBLE
PRECEDENT.
MICHAEL HOROWITZ WHO WAS
CONFIRMED UNANIMOUSLY AS AN
OBAMA POINT HE DID A VERY
THOROUGH JOB.
IF JAMES COMEY THINKS HE’S WON
THE DAY, ARE YOU KIDDING?
THE FIRST REPORT SAID HE ACT IS
AS INSUBORDINATE.
IT IS AS DAMNING AS ANY REPORT
YOU WILL EVER SEE FROM
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
I DO THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE
PROSECUTED.
JAMES COMEY IS NOT OUT OF THE
WOODS.
YOU HAVE TWO PLACES OF
VULNERABILITY.
ONE IS THE CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE
SUPREME COURT BECAUSE ONCE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL DOES THE FISA
REPORT, THEY COULD VERY WELL
HOLD PEOPLE IN CONTEMPT AND
JAMES COMEY’S AUTOGRAPH IS ON
ONE OF THOSE THINGS AND THE
SUPREME COURT SHOULD ACTUALLY
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
MISLEADING ON THE FISA ABUSE.
THE SECOND ONE IS THE REPORT ON
THE FISA ABUSE.
JAMES COMEY IS NOT OUT OF THE
WOODS ON THAT.
>> Juan: WE HAVEN’T SEEN
ANYTHING ABOUT ALL THE TALK
ABOUT FISA WARRANT AND THE LIKE
TO THIS POINT.
DANA, IN ASKING ABOUT THIS, WHAT
DO YOU THINK SHOULD BE THE
PENALTY?
HE DID, ACCORDING TO THE REPORT,
VIOLATE POLICY BUT THEY ARE
SAYING HE DIDN’T BREAK THE LAW.
APPARENTLY THESE MEMOS WERE NOT
CLASSIFIED.
>> Dana: IT FEELS A LOT TO ME
LIKE SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
BACK IN 2015 AN ’16 WHEN HE WAS
THE FBI DIRECTOR.
HE’S DOING A VICTORY LAP SORT OF
LIKE HILLARY CLINTON DID A
VICTORY LAP AFTER JAMES COMEY
DECLINED TO OFFICIALLY CHARGE
HER FOR HAVING THE PRIVATE EMAIL
SERVER, AND A LOT OF THESE
THINGS ARE VERY SIMILAR.
THE RETENTION AND HANDLING OF
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS.
IT’S ALMOST AS IF IT’S KIND OF A
MIRROR IMAGE BECAUSE IT’S THE
SAME STATUTE OR THE SAME POLICY
GUIDELINE THAT HE DECIDED NOT TO
OFFICIALLY CHARGE, NOW THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS SAYING WE
ARE NOT GOING TO PROSECUTE BUT
NOBODY IS SAYING THIS IS A GOOD
THING TO DO.
I HAVE A FEELING THAT IF
SOMEBODY THAT WORKED FOR
JIM COMEY AT THE FBI HAD DONE
THIS VERY THING AND JIM COMEY
FOUND OUT ABOUT IT, THAT PERSON
PROBABLY WOULD’VE BEEN FIRED OR
AT LEAST PUT ON THE SUSPENSION.
BUT HIS TWEETS, I HAVE TO SAY,
IT’S GOOD TO BE ON OFFENSE VIEW
CAN BE.
EVEN WHEN IT LOOKS LIKE YOU
SHOULD BE ON DEFENSE, HE’S JUST
ON OFFENSE AND HE LEARNED THAT
FROM OUR RECENT POLITICS.
IT WORKS.
>> Juan: HE LEARNED IT FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Dana: NOT ONLY BAD.
IF YOU LOOK AT HILLARY CLINTON,
SHE WALKED -- JIM COMEY
BASICALLY SAID SHE DID ALL THESE
TERRIBLE THINGS AND SHE WALKED
OUT AND SAID I’M GOOD.
HOW DARE ANYBODY SAY I DID
SOMETHING WRONG?
>> Juan: I WAS THINKING
DEMOCRATS ARE ANGRY AND
JIM COMEY BECAUSE TEN DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION HE CAME OUT
AND SENT A LETTER TO CONGRESS
SAYING I’M GOING TO REOPEN THIS
INVESTIGATION, NEVER MENTIONING
THERE WAS AN ONGOING PROBE INTO
TRUMP’S CAMPAIGN.
DO YOU THINK RIGHT NOW WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THIS AND YOU SAY YOU
KNOW, HE WAS TALKING TO THE
PRESIDENT AND THE PRESIDENT WAS
ASKING HIM TO GO LIGHT ON MIKE
FLYNN, DO YOU SEE ANY WAY TO
JUSTIFY HIS BEHAVIOR?
>> Greg: I WILL ALWAYS GIVE
COMEY CREDIT FOR HAVING BOTH
SIDES HATE HIM.
HE HAS MANAGED TO PISS OFF
EVERYBODY.
THERE IS SOMETHING REDEEMING
ABOUT SOMEONE EVERYBODY HATES.
I HAVE TO GO BACK TO THIS
VICTORY LAP.
IT WAS A ONE-MAN -- IT WAS A
ONE-MAN FIST BUMP.
HE WENT UP LIKE THIS.
THERE’S NOBODY THERE.
THERE’S NOBODY THERE TO FIST
BUMP.
HE’S DOING A ONE-MAN HIGH FIVE.
IT REMINDS ME OF ME CLAIMING
VICTORY WHEN MY WIFE FINDS ONLY
FOUR EMPTY BEER BOTTLES AND NOT
EIGHT.
ONLY GOT ME FOR LEAKING PHONY
STUFF TO THE PRESS AND I’M NOT
GOING TO JAIL.
I WIN.
MY WORRY IS I HOPE IT IS IN
HINDER HIS CHANCES IN BECOMING A
CNN CONTRIBUTOR BECAUSE I THINK
HE PROVED THEM RIGHT.
WHAT DID WE LEARN FROM WHAT HE
DID WRONG?
HE DESIGNATED A BUDDY TO LEAK
INFO TO "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THIS WAS A GUY WHO’S ALWAYS
INTERESTED IN THE MEDIA PIECE.
MORE THAN ANYTHING HE WAS ALWAYS
INTO THE SPOTLIGHT AND HE ALWAYS
USED TO COVER IT UP IN THIS AW
SHUCKS MENTALITY.
IT CAMOUFLAGES A NARCISSISTIC
MAN AND HE SHOULD GO TO JAIL FOR
LIFE.
IF THERE WAS A DEATH PENALTY, I
WOULD PUSH FOR IT.
IT IS DOUBLE DEEP STATE.
DOUBLE DEEP STATE.
OR MAYBE DEEP DOUBLE STATE.
EITHER WAY, ITS DEEP DISH DOUBLE
STATE.
[LAUGHTER]
DEEP DISH.
>> Emily: CAN I PIGGYBACK --
>> Greg: PIGGYBACK ON MY
DEEP STATE?
>> Emily: I DON’T THINK THAT.
THE HUBRIS, THE NARCISSISM.
THE IG REPORT, YOU’RE RIGHT, IT
IS AS DAMNING AS THEY COME.
ONE BIG "WHAT WERE YOU
THINKING?"
FIRST OF ALL, NO, IT’S NOT YOUR
PERSONAL DIARY.
IT STILL CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
THE IG SAYS LITERALLY WHOLLY
UNSUBSTANTIATED AS WELL AS
PLAINLY STATED IN THE CODE.
YOU WOULD THINK AN ACTING
DIRECTOR WOULD UNDERSTAND THAT.
IN TERMS OF DISSEMINATING THE
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION, HIS
DEFENSE IN THE INTERVIEWS DURING
THE INVESTIGATION WAS I DID IT
BECAUSE I LOVE MY COUNTRY.
MEANWHILE ALL OF THE OTHER
ACTORS WENT ON THE RECORD SAYING
THEY WERE SHOCKED AND STUNNED
AND DISAPPOINTED AND SURPRISED.
THE IG WAS LIKE, YOU’RE NOT A
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
YOU ARE JUST STRAIGHT UP
BREAKING THE LAW AND YOU BROKE
POLICY.
THE MEMOS TO HIS ATTORNEYS
THE FBI LEARNED ABOUT HIM GIVING
LITERALLY DURING HIS
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONIES AND
ALL THOSE GUYS, THEY WERE
CALLING DURING THE TESTIMONY TO
TRY TO GET THAT CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
>> Juan: LET ME INTERRUPT YOU
FOR A SECOND.
HIS ARGUMENT WAS AND I THINK
WHAT THE REPORT SAYS, THESE WERE
NOT CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
>> Emily: AND THE ANSWER WAS
YES, THEY WERE.
>> Juan: THEY WERE
SUBSEQUENTLY MAY BE CLASSIFIED
BUT NOT WHEN HE --
>> Greg: THAT USUALLY WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> Dana: IT’S NOT LIKE HE WAS
WRITING DOWN HIS TO-DO LIST OF
THINGS HE NEEDED TO DO AROUND
THE HOUSE.
HE WAS WRITING INFORMATION THAT
HAD TO DO WITH HIS GOVERNMENT,
HIS PRESIDENT.
YOU CAN’T JUST SAY THOSE ARE NOT
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS.
THE PRESS SECRETARY, YOU TAKE
DOWN NOTES IN A MEETING, THOSE
NOTES HAVE TO GO INTO THE FILE.
YOU DON’T GET TO THROW THEM
AWAY.
>> Juan: HERE’S MY POINT TO
YOU.
THIS IS A TRUMP JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THAT JUST MADE THIS
DECISION THAT IN FACT HE IS NOT
TO BE PROSECUTED.
>> Emily: I WILL SAY THEY
DECLINED TO PROSECUTE THIS BUT
PRESENTLY WE HAVE THE IG
INVESTIGATING THE FBI FOR THEIR
CONDUCT DURING THE ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION AND WE ALSO HAVE
TWO SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS BY
THE DOJ, U.S. ATTORNEY FOR
CONNECTICUT AND TOP INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS INTO THE ORIGINS OF
THE MUELLER PROBE.
HE IS NOT OUT OF THE CLEAR --
WHATEVER IT IS, >> Juan: IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU ARE WISHING THEY
CAUGHT HIM BUT THEY DIDN’T.
ANDREW MCCABE, WHERE IT THAT’S
IT.
THERE’S BEEN NO PROSECUTION.
>> Jason: TWO THINGS REAL
QUICKLY.
BY SEPARATING OUT JAMES COMEY,
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THE SCENES THEY BELIEVE
THAT THAT IS REALLY BAD NEWS FOR
McCABE, STRZOK, PAGE, OHR.
IF THEY ARE GOING TO GIVE COMEY
A PASS, THESE OTHERS HAVE A
GREAT DEAL OF VULNERABILITY
AHEAD OF THEM AND THE SECOND
POINT, I THINK THE OBAMA-BIDEN
LEGACY IS GOING TO BE THE
POLITICIZATION OF PUTTING
POLITICS INTO THE WORST OF THE
WORST.
YOU’RE SUPPOSED TO HAVE AN FBI,
A DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, THE
IRS, FEDERAL RESERVE, THEY ARE
ALL SUPPOSED TO BE ABOVE AND
BEYOND POLITICS.
AND YET WHERE WE ARE EIGHT YEARS
LATER, NINE YEARS LATER, THEY
HAVE POLITICIZED SOME OF THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT SHOULD BE ON
POLITICS.
IF THERE IS NOTHING ELSE FROM
JAMES COMEY AND WHAT YOU SAW IN
THE IG, IT’S THAT THEY USE THIS
THE FIRST AND SECOND REPORT FROM
FOR THEIR OWN PERSONAL
GRATIFICATION, THEIR OWN
PERSONAL POLITICAL AGENDA AND
THEY POLITICIZE THESE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES AND
THAT’S IMPORTANT WHAT’S TEARING
UP THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE THEY
DON’T BELIEVE THERE IS AN OF
JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
>> Greg: TO SUMMARIZE THAT,
THANKS, OBAMA.
>> Juan: THERE YOU GO.
YOU REALIZE JIM COMEY IS A
REPUBLICAN.
>> Jason: RIGHT.
WHAT DID HE DONATE, $20,000 TO
DEMOCRATS?
>> Juan: I DON’T KNOW.
>> Jason: HE HAS BEEN
DISINGENUOUS.
HE’S NO REPUBLICAN, NO
CONSERVATIVE.
>> Juan: I THINK THE RECORD
SAYS HE’S A CONSERVATIVE AND
REPUBLICAN IN THE SAME THING --
YOU STOP AND LOOK AT
ROBERT MUELLER.
HE’S A REPUBLICAN.
>> Jason: TO GREG’S POINT, WE
BOTH ARE ABSENT AND